so I saw the six minute prologue of the
Dark Knight Rises in IMAX and with every
six minute prologue of a Dark Knight
movie comes a couple minute long video
from me alright so in this prologue it
starts out a couple of guys get brought
to the FBI the FBI is looking for Bain
so they take a couple of Bane's goons
that they've captured onto this plane
that's the one thing I heard about this
prologue I heard that there was like
planes in it and of course Bane has a
plan and so you see Bane in action any
here Bane talk what I like about this is
it does what a prologue should do is
shows how Bane operates and the Joker
and vain are completely different people
and I like how this really Illustrated
that just how other guys interact with
him you know I mean the Joker's guys he
controlled them through manipulation and
fear you know he was having them picked
off and they didn't want to die there
were hired goons to do a job The Joker's
guys are not loyal to the Joker to the
death or loyal to him cuz they like well
if I backstab him he's gonna burn me on
top of pile of money or something it was
really apparent that Bane's guys are
loyal to Bane because they're loyal to
him and his cause like to the deaths
they're like at the mission calls for me
to die I die you know the fire Rises so
you see that Bane is a badass Bane's a
man with a plan he's really smart he's a
big dude and after that it's exciting
instead of a heist movie also you know
instead of a bank you're in a plane the
one thing the complaint I have is
actually Payne's voice which people
complained about it though like dude
Jeremy Baines voice you know it's hard
to understand what he's saying and that
was just yeah I was ignorant I didn't
hear his voice I was like what does it
sound like he has a mask on probably
because he's wearing a mask dude it
makes sense then I saw the prologue and
I was like yeah I hope they do something
about that voice it's hard to understand
him he sounds like he has his nose plug
and he's wearing a mask so I hope they
fixed that just saying I wish between
his voice and Batman's hugs voice maybe
it'll be like the movie assassins two
guys you cannot understand but by the
end of the movie maybe you can actually
adapt and understand what they're saying
[Music]
believe in the good Hawker pack so
that's my complaint is his voice but
this prologue does exactly what it's
supposed to do and that is get you
jacked up for the Dark Knight Rises the
worst part is that it ends when it ends
your like I wanted to see more you do
have a couple of questions though he
does like a blood transfusion from this
one guy they're like why is he draining
the guy's blood is he a vampire so you
don't know why you it's left you with
questions
so the prologues cool it has a badass
villain who is smart he's not the
[ __ ] who was in Batman and Robin that
was in vain it was Bigfoot with a mask
smart Bane with loyal troops that's what
we get in the Dark Knight Rises so it
seems so it's cool as hell and you got
to see it in IMAX don't underestimate
the size of the IMAX screen either if
you're sitting right in the middle
you're like oh yeah this is far enough
back it's not move a couple rows back
it's big and at the very end of the
prologue it has like he knows it's doing
the Batman theme and it's showing like
scenes and whatnot one thing it shows
it's really cool Bane's walking I think
it was raining at the time and he's
holding a broken Batman mask it looks
like the broken mass it's in the poster
and he just drops it on the ground
that's the end so I was like okay it's
not just to be supposed to art it's
official Batman does get his ass beat I
want to see this movie so are you gonna
see the Dark Knight Rises prologue have
you seen the Dark Knight Rises trailer I
will do a video on that too I promise
what did you think of all this comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]